this plant holds special hidden presents
does this look tasty not really but if
you open it up
it's like tropical fruit mixed with a
tomato it's called the peach very
tropical it tastes like pastry fruit and
mango
inside is more like africa
[Music]
very brightly and it's popped
yeah
it's iceborn it looks like it covered
with water but
it's actually not water droplets have
crystallized for some reason outside of
their bodies i feel like this tastes
like a cold walk
it's actually a name we created but it's
a type of wild arugula to go after its
sweet heat
[Music]
if i told you we've got wasabi roots
growing somewhere down here you'd
actually believe it
in here
the flowers are insanely delicious oh
wow i'm dying
like to a tea right
these beautiful things are called okas
and they're actually a kind of vegetable
[Music]
whoa these are a type of wood soil
called trumpet sorrels you can pick off
one of these yellow flowers and they're
gonna taste like lemons
so you can eat it you can absolutely eat
it and they're delicious here try one
it's so sour
if you've ever gotten sesame leaves from
the korean market this might be where
you got them from wow so you're looking
at where they come from not to be
confused with the sesame seeds sesame
leaf is used in some what you can use to
wrap your meats and vegetables when you
eat like puckering my tongue it makes me
realize that all flavors are just
combinations of other flavors
i don't drop acid but if i did
this is what i imagine i might see we
thought the tomatoes weren't ready but
we found one that was
straight up legit completely ready acid
those tomatoes that you've seen in
grocery store shelves have basically sat
there for god knows how long this part
why it's it's like very puffy relative
to like what i think most tomatoes look
like succulent like for lack of a better
term
my friend is all
the fact that you just picked it if it's
not this vibrant
you know how long it's been sitting
[Music]
this one is more
floral
it's floral because it's flowers i'm not
sure this was edible
you